well science is just a bunch of tools  and there's nothing magic about science  it just happens I'm enjoying mathematics  I enjoy calculating things so I make a  living doing science I don't regard that  as a big any particular qualification to  be wise but it is the most important  thing about science as far as the public  is concerned is it is a real  international activity we really do  operate with our friends all over the  world so we have very good connections  with countries which normally regarded  as enemies that's why we are useful I  would say for this kind of situation you  want to talk about nuclear weapons not  just with your friends you want to talk  with your enemies scientists are the  best people to do that because they  happen to know their enemies already  [Music]  [Music]